la infografía coronaria es un examen
radio gráfico del corazón
este examen permite ver los vasos
sanguíneos del corazón llamados arterias
coronarias puede determinar si una
sustancia cerosa llamada placa ha
estrechado estos vasos
además muestra que también funcionan las
válvulas y las cavidades del corazón
y la angiografía coronaria a menudo se
realiza a través de un procedimiento
médico llamado cateterismo cardíaco
antes del procedimiento lo colocan sobre
una mesa con un dispositivo de rayos x
llamado fluoroscopio
por lo general el cateterismo cardíaco
se realiza a través de la arteria radial
de la muñeca esta vía normalmente tiene
menos sangrado y complicaciones
a veces en su lugar se utiliza la
arteria femoral de la ingle
para comenzar el doctor insensibiliza la
piel de la muñeca se inserta una aguja
en la arteria radial a través de esta
aguja se pasa un alambre el alambre se
guía suavemente a través de las arterias
hasta el corazón la aguja se saca y se
reemplaza con un tubo flexible pequeño
llamado vaina esto permite el acceso a
la arteria radial
y luego sobre el alambre se desliza un
tubo blando y flexible llamado catéter a
través de la vaina el catéter se
desplaza hasta el corazón
y luego él fluoroscopio se mueve por
encima del pecho para tomar radiografías
del corazón
el médico usa las radiografías para
controlar el catéter es posible que
sienta presión cuando se le coloca el
alambre y la vaina pero no lo sentirá
dentro de las arterias
una vez que el catéter llega hasta las
arterias coronarias el alambre se retira
la punta del catéter se posiciona justo
dentro de cada arteria para inyectar un
tinte especial este tinte le permite al
fluoroscopio tomar radiografías de las
arterias llamadas angiogramas cuando las
arterias se llenan de tinte se puede
identificar claramente cualquier
obstrucción puede que se sienta
acalorado o con leves náuseas cuando se
inyecta el tinte al final del
procedimiento se quita el catéter a
través de la muñeca
se coloca una banda de presión sobre la
arteria radial para prevenir el sangrado
luego se quita la vaina
la banda de presión permanece en la
muñeca hasta que el sangrado se detenga
para obtener más información sobre la
angiografía coronaria habla con su
proveedor de atención médica